[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about what
whatever wow and uh
good morning it's a morning session and
uh i've spilled coffee on myself and i'm
gonna be annoyed by that stain all day
how's your quarantine been girl i
haven't seen you in like a month
i know i haven't seen you guys forever
but after having breakfast with you guys
everything just feels just right right
like back to normal yeah
i mean it's just it's just a nice
breather uh i've just been
working at home uh our
show our animation show is actually in
production now so it's actually a lot
easier
is it going on netflix yeah it'll be on
netflix
she's working on a netflix i think next
summer i'm not sure i mean depending on
how cobid goes like
it'll probably it might be delayed but
it's aiming for next summer it's
animated right
it's animated yeah so if you are are you
ever
like i guess on set or is it just like
in production means the animators are
just
going at it now uh animators aren't
going at it right
now but um we're in the beginning part
of production so the animation is like
the second half of it
oh people like like doing the voiceover
yeah
yeah so we have the voice actors
recording and then we also
um have like designers like creating the
characters the props the backgrounds and
then we have um storyboard artists to
like
figure out the camera angle so it's it's
all in that and then we put that all
together in a bundle and then
put it to animation that's dope are you
guys working out of an
office now or not not yet everyone's
still working from home um
well the thing is so prior to quarantine
i was like in a different building and
then our studio was actually going to
move into like a bigger building so like
all the studios can be in one place but
uh cove would have it and so then uh
now everyone's pretty much working from
home but we don't even know when our
office is
going to be open yeah they're they want
to be careful that everyone's like safe
and like they don't want to force people
to go into the office because they want
to make sure that like
you know we're not spreading draw from
home yeah yeah i mean because everything
can be done remotely
for even the voiceovers but yeah they
actually figured out a way to record
them
what did they send like equipment and
like a sound booth to their homes and
then they just set it up and like all
right
so how are they recording it like if
this is the drawing right like and then
they have a phone like this and they go
action and then they start flipping in
like that yeah is that how they make the
no no no no so what so i guess uh for
how we're gonna do it it's just that um
the voice actors record
their lines and then the animators based
off those recordings
draw accordingly yeah that's cool this
is so much cooler than jk julia
what do you mean yeah i mean i like i
like both
it has to we have to compare them i'm
just one has to be better than the other
no we have to
that's the world we live in you can't
just like something you have to compare
it to the old you have to hate the whole
thing and run away from it completely
you have to pick it outside you have to
make a buzzfeed video like why i left
buzzfeed and talk a lot of [ __ ] about us
yes
except that we don't have y left buzz we
have y left jk news which you already
did but you didn't talk about
that you weren't polarizing dude you
already had like you only got like 400
000 views
i'm so disappointed i think i taught you
better than this [ __ ] you would have had
a million views why didn't you tell the
truth julia yeah the truth
okay look this is how we do youtube okay
we love each other in real life but we
hate each other on camera
yeah [ __ ] you too goc that's how we do
youtube and we want you to make a video
of why i left jk news
oh my god yeah you gotta like stretch
this [ __ ]
you have to tell everyone you have to
tell uh how everyone's [ __ ] everyone
everyone was [ __ ] everyone yeah you
gotta be like essentially harassed
the office conditions is so cold in
there yeah oh it's so cold
if she does talk about not getting
sunlight in here that's true we really
don't have any windows we have no
windows
we have no windows it's like a dungeon
it does get cold that is not my branding
please respect my brain my bosses are
always naked around me can you believe
that your body needs vitamin d by the
way
they're harming your body and your
eyeballs
oh why you think she's so damn light we
never give her we never gave her
something i can't wear glasses but i
don't put them on in here because i'm so
afraid of seeing my naked bosses
yeah maybe i'm just so used to it that i
don't think it's anything out of the
norm
i think that that's probably the truest
thing that's been said so far yeah
you poor girl or if you go to your new
office and you go
hey i can't pay attention to these zoom
meetings unless people are [ __ ] naked
yeah or julia goes to her new office
she's like it's hot in here she just
takes off her shirt
i would have to say it was quite a
culture shock for me like work-wise
work-wise because i was like
whoa everything's like perfectly clean
no i'm just like it's just it's just a
different workflow like oh
isn't it stiff stiff no actually no
everyone's pretty
what is the difference it's not going to
pick a side i can't have her do it i
can't have her too
can we talk some [ __ ] somewhere like
about us or them when they get mad they
put expensive weapons through the wall
oh not very cheap ones oh very true yeah
because they have a netflix budget
yeah yeah yeah so they put a real accent
well i have a real axe that i use
i think i think i'm more um starstruck
oh you see stars here
i don't know if i see stars here
you're star struck at the anime artist
yeah but huh you star struck with the
anime artist
uh yeah artist and um the voice actors
this is all your [ __ ]
one who's the one i can't see it can't
say something
you got this is the reason why she's
gone you [ __ ]
you guys [ __ ] drove her out of jknews
[ __ ] you guys there you go that's
controversial you see
this is why she's not on jk news anymore
not because i wanted to follow my dreams
and it's because you were driven
out by negativity that's why that's
because it's it's all the negative
people's faults
the people that you see that you're star
struck by do i know them yeah do we know
that am i like oh i know that guy
too yes you would oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] tell
me what kind of stuff
you do yeah i signed an nda list
you know what you can do we're gonna
figure this out you could tell us the
name of the stars that's not their name
rhyme's life yeah brian bree chris
how many how many degrees from kevin
bacon
i can't say i'm not going to say
anything i don't want to get in trouble
ranzell
mashington dang [ __ ]
can you imagine denzel washington doing
a cartoon anime show
his voice would be good for it it would
you know who i miss was isaac hayes
on uh south park me too chef yeah
yeah he has a really deep voice uh he
died well he was also a scientologist
yeah and he got driven off of the show
by them hating on scientology so hard
that yeah
he was like he got driven off by the
show creators well he couldn't support
that because he's a scientologist and he
felt like so he just walked
away from the world he quit he quit yeah
because trey matt wouldn't let up
gotcha yeah and then and then they also
used
some of his voice recordings to
basically take the piss out of what he
did
yeah that's after it he left it was
pretty great because they used his old
videos
and then they mashed it up and because
they have his voice for like [ __ ]
300 hours or something so they just they
mashed up something
oh these guys are [ __ ] savages man
yeah so you like where you're at right
now you're having a good time
whack yeah i'm having a great time
having a fantastic
time no she's never coming back now
[ __ ] well she's here where did you
forget what is your job title over there
uh actually got promoted i'm a
production coordinator now see
i hate how we [ __ ] train people so
good here that when they leave like
they're just so good outside you got to
take skills away from people
how did you get a promotion so damn fast
that's less than six months
yeah i was actually really surprised um
because everyone died of corona so
they're like
julia's moving up that could be no i
think
i think because like a good chunk of
hollywood has closed like a lot of
animation studios are getting more uh
projects and more jobs
so i think a lot of like a lot of people
who are in coordinator positions like
weren't available
how many kitchen coordinator your
production coordinate
how many people work in the building
when they're when it was open
um i don't know we have like a few
thousand but a thousand people
yeah oh you guys are doing some serious
[ __ ] because when i did when i did
cartoons it was like 30 people max like
at maker
and but we and we had like just like a
it was like big i thought but like
[ __ ] a thousand people's crazy
that's a lot of people that's a lot
i took a thousand people to make one
cartoon
you no does it take a thousand people to
make one cartoons
it can be less for like a show
maybe like yeah are they making multiple
shows is that one yeah
simultaneously producing a ton of shows
oh that makes sense
oh that's cool i guess you know
i mean i mean i i miss i miss all of
your guys's individual charm
uh pictures of us yeah on your desk
yeah yeah yeah can we go like this like
yes
please we missed you got it you know
what sucks is like
i wanted like a legit legit party uh
but we all went to dinner together and i
wanted like a party party party
like i want to go on vacation julia's
the one that always plans it and now
she's gone
and no one planned it and it took me and
bart
like three months after you guys left to
really plan it or whatever
and that's all you came up with well we
didn't plan it also snacks has never
been the same yeah i know
i'm looking at it i'm just like i'm so
sad
i don't think we even ordered more
snacks since you left
can you order us you are the blue you
understand that you were the glue
and now that you're gone no one can feel
you there's a void a snap
there's everything planning everything
void fine what
what if i come back for like a day it's
working huh
you have to quit though you can't work
at two places at once a day's not enough
well one way i mean but like if it's
just to plan
parties and to like stock up if you want
to make more money
uh-huh you're always welcome to here
that's all i'm saying
that was myself nice sell i'm here now i
know right and you're making money to
al-qaeda do you like to make more money
or less money yeah
who's the kind of person that likes to
make less money
we should be considered a money boy or a
girl she could be a money girl i'm
seeing it i'm starting to see it
she is a go-getter yeah definitely do
you guys know their program that they
have
they have a new money masters program
you guys what do you do you guys
julia guys
the multiple layers of julia yeah so my
co-workers are just like
oh i'm a big fan of of you of
all of us you're the celebrity of all of
us how does it feel to be like a
celebrity in a [ __ ] how many
autographs did you sign
yeah not that many people know about me
but like the few that dude they're like
oh my god i'm such a big fan like tell
everyone i love them and i'm like okay
you didn't even say it that's tight you
didn't even tell us we always do that
though huh
so don't even bother being like hey can
you tell so and so that i love them
and i'm all like for sure and i don't
tell
i don't tell them but i will from now on
at the meet and greet i'll start calling
people i'll be like hey bart
all right uh what's your name edgar all
right edgar wants you to know that he
loves you all right cool
when i was first new to youtube i
remember people reaching out and being
like hey can you get like
everybody like they sent me something
and like can you get everybody
to sign this so they wanted shane dawson
and like shay carl all these people
and i was like this is a [ __ ] lot of
work but eventually it took me like four
months but i got everyone to sign this
thing oh wow
that good yeah and i sent it to this to
this person
and never got a [ __ ] thank you yeah
so i was like that's a fine how do you
do
was this like a family member no this is
just something i was so nervous i asked
you to do it yeah
it was like obviously it was like a
younger person yeah had to be like
in their teens early teens and i and
they sent me a nice little note and like
asked me to do that
and how how do you feel when you guys
get used
yeah i got used like that yeah and
they're like hey man
so joe like i've been watching you guys
but my favorite
really is like geo i was wondering if
you could pass this message on
to her it's the best and i'm like why
don't because she's not responding to me
yeah but you are because you obviously
have all this free time to talk to me
[Laughter]
so i wanted to let her know it is sad
i'm all like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know how i feel like i feel like the
okay looking girl with a really hot
girlfriend
and then like all the guys are like
hitting me up like can you tell your
friend like
i'm like [ __ ] what about me the best is
when dude you just
love the joe but the best is when dudes
hit us up to
give a message to our wives like hey i
love your
like tell nikki i love her and i'm like
no
tell your wife on a boner yeah right
it's like no [ __ ] you
is it cool if i [ __ ] your wife one day
like that's basically what they're
saying right
this is what i missed from my workplace
this is what i think people are saying
is real [ __ ]
yeah oh do they do like office talk
where it's not really like
water cooler talk yeah they don't really
go an extra level it's deeper it's just
oh how are you oh good
okay cool you have a cocker spaniel
i love congress is it like that
yeah i mean because of you i'm trying to
get to know everyone so it's kind of
like that and then also like in the
meetings like
do you ask like hey are you divorced no
like just ask me
the real question do we ask that here
yeah
we know if who's divorced right now
that's right this is the realness i'm
missing from my old work see that's the
thing that's
this is it just crazy what do you mean
well you're probably not in meetings
like hey do you ever want to [ __ ] your
friend
that's true i mean hey if the
opportunity arises sure i'll ask
okay this is this feels so good thank
you for having me back on jk news guys
great does it feel like when you're
there you're not
truly like relaxed because
you just you're just in this different
world you're like oh right there's
boundaries like i can't say certain
things right
because i'm so used to um working with
my friends
that sometimes when i'm in a uh all the
restaurant meetings right
those there's new people coming in and
they they come from other
businesses and and they're new hirees
and we'll go
off and i see their eyes and they're
like this and i'm like
[ __ ] wait a minute it's always fun
looking at the new people just to see
what their reaction is to you guys this
pool goes
i'm hot and he takes off his shirt and
[ __ ] and he's in shorts and then he
starts [ __ ] talking like all business
and stuff
and i'm out here barefoot and being like
in the middle you see my [ __ ] foot
dog
damn so the other day i was jacking off
and this and that and i'm like oh [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden bart starts
wrestling no he's wrestling david
and david's getting choked out to the
ground
no i mean like when when i do hear a
co-worker of mine say something crazy
i'm like oh
feels just like home what's crazy
crazier than the [ __ ] that you've heard
of here
like it's like it's very mild yeah it's
like very mild but like it just gives me
a taste of oh
i missed just the remembrance you're
like oh i'm so mad right now i could
like poop
and you're like that's some jk thing
yeah i do feel like i have to like be
careful of what i say yeah you're pretty
you're pretty raw too yeah nothing's
ever slipped up she's been ruined by us
i know literally sometimes like when i
write emails i'm like oh [ __ ] i gotta
rewrite this dude this doesn't sound
have you have you told any of your
co-workers about your butt [ __ ]
stories
oh my god recently recently my co-worker
uh she she was like oh yeah you know my
son he wants to go into youtube and i
hear that you used to be on youtube and
i was like
oh yeah i was like for like six years
and then she was like yeah so i googled
you and the first video that popped up
was
talking about sex and then i was just
like
out of all the videos you do so where'd
you go from there
did you go i didn't even do it the
regular way my first time was a
different
it was the alternative route i forgot i
forgot what the title was
i didn't want my virginity to be taken
at that moment and we didn't have
condoms or was she like
me too
it wasn't like that it was it was uh no
no no
she was just like say that and i was
just like oh my god i can't believe
you've seen that and then she was like
yeah but that's just something that like
you know my son's interested in going
into so like she was just like moving
forward the conversation so she didn't
really
dwell on it too much but i just thought
it was really funny because she said it
during like
a casual like group meeting where we're
just all hanging out so she's kind of
like i know but i'm not gonna burn you
out
oh no i mean she said it like in the
whole group and i was just like
oh i can't move it like that's the first
i mean like there's some other wholesome
content that you can probably watch
jk party jk parties is probably the most
is it
i don't know julia when you got hired
when you're in there for the interview
yeah are they like
uh so you used to do youtube huh yeah
what's the link
what's the link yeah yeah no you did
youtube right what's the link i put the
company name on there oh you did yeah i
[ __ ] wear a proud
dude it's [ __ ] right here on my
[ __ ] entertainment
[Laughter]
if you come here your resume is
tarnished forever
unless you're going into entertainment
no no no it's not tarnished i managed to
still get a job outside of jake it's not
tarnish guys it's not tarnished it's
because they couldn't find the channel
no they found something else obviously
yeah if i get fired i'll just be like
hey guys can i come back that's the cool
thing about
the thing here is you always you'll
always have a place except for certain
people
but you julia you'll have a place you'll
have a you
[Laughter]
i don't think time is up i think we
edited some stuff out actually yeah we
got a lot of time
for some fillers fine we'll throw out a
letter we'll throw out a letter do you
know a job
that you can get paid for collecting
stacks at costco
there's probably a job out there it's so
it's called something right it's just it
was it assistant systematically uh all
kinds of snacks
yeah or uh getter i mean production
coordinator is kind of similar
yeah i mean when uh so i started off as
a pa there and i was literally buying
snacks for them
were you bringing in the asian [ __ ] no
no no no no did they have
the area that i was in wasn't very did
they have a good budget though
it's probably way better than first i
don't know i can't find nothing wrong
about them i hate that thousands of
employees
i hate them too just think about our
current snack budget that you set up for
me
times four not 10 before jesus
they probably even have like a working
100 bucks
actually no no sorry
[Laughter]
i don't even remember our snack budget
girl you gave me 100 a month
so that's 400 bucks a month i know but
then i did the math
wrong so so ty is that by two are you
saying that 800 a month
oh [ __ ] we have a thousand people that's
are you buying it four thousand or just
the people on the floor or the
just the people for just the show
specifically are you saying they have
four mini fridges
no they don't have many fridges but they
have one big fridge they have a big we
got three fridges though
do they have a bar right there at the
place yeah yeah they actually they
actually have a
beer on top oh my god on tap
yeah what kind of [ __ ] is this i'm not
that tap sorry on the
keg what kind of company are we in yeah
this is [ __ ] i'm out of here
big dude [ __ ] this company
do you want to apply you want to yeah i
do buy yeah i'm going into the cartoons
yeah are we can we are we all carp
guys i got nuts
i got nuts and hot sauce yeah let's get
the beer on tap
unsalted nuts
[Music]
you